- [Interviewer] What's
more important to you?
Love or money.
- Money, Shit you know with
money I can buy some love
- [Interviewer] AP, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Memphis. I
grew up in Northern area
- [Interviewer] North Memphis?
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young.
- Yeah. Yeah. Until, you
know, prioritize like seven.
They were separated. So my mom,
she raised me and two of my brothers.
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- Well, you know, I describe
it as good, you know
never handle where it was. And I was just
and I was just did
everything nervous I was do
for school or whatever.
Then, you know, I tried to
try to be sneaking stuff
you know, selling drugs and, you know
got into a situation when my
mom found out went from there.
So after then I was 11 years old.
Yeah. They, they gave me off the porch.
So I just continued on, you
know, just trying to make
and ends meet as, you know,
six air drills or whatever.
And there, I was still
going to school until I
just completely stopped going
to school and made green.
This green was drowning and,
you know, just making money
putting up buying cars and seals, etc
and just, you know, started
this, you know, this
I went there and I had
my first shot I was 15.
- [Interviewer] So how
far did you go in school.
I went, I went to nine
grade it wasn't was great.
I stopped going to school in ninth.
- [Interviewer] And you started working
as a pimp at what point?
- Well, I'm going to say,
you know, he started walking
he started paying me what
I apparently was born about
you know what I'm saying?
So, you know, that's why I born a pimp.
I just didn't know.
I didn't put it into perspective
until I was old enough
to know what a pimp was you
understand what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Did you
have it in your family
or did you have friends
that showed you the ropes?
- Yeah, you know, it
was basically, you know
a lot older guys that was
around my neighborhood
or whatever, you know,
they was doing everything
and I'm just sitting back
looking at as a young
young pup I'm watching
like, and they got nice cars
and playing the jury and,
man, I'm a chatter, you know
sneak up on a little, come
home and just had went.
- [Interviewer] What was the
hardest part of learning?
- The hardest part.
- [Interviewer] What was the
hardest part of learning?
How to do this, saving money?
- Yeah, You know, it's just like, you know
if you know what I'm saying
when you pay me, you know,
payments, put it in my pocket
you understand what I'm saying?
So with that being said, you
know, it's just, they gotta
you know, you gotta,
you gotta, you can get
I mean, females, Jose, well,
you ain't got no choice.
I said, well, then you do have a choice.
You get in line or get out of line.
So, you know, there's
just, what's going on.
And then it hit me and
you two minute, you know
you have two minutes,
you don't have a one time
one chance not to pay my money. You know?
And then honestly, as you go on, you know
like the money disappeared.
That's why I make you
do disappear. You know?
- [Interviewer] So your style
is what there's gorilla pimps
there's finesse, pimps there's all kinds
of different styles. How
would you describe yourself?
- Let's see. So any kind
of pimp, all kinds of pimps
ain't no, you know what I'm saying?
, whatever, whatever
type of hoe I'm dealing
with, this, what kind of
pimp you understand me
- [Interviewer] To adapt for the girl?
And how many girls do you have?
- Shit five.
- [Interviewer] And what
nationality of these girls are?
They African-American white, Hispanic?
- Yeah right now You
know, I'm in the process
of the hoes that I'm putting him
on the pay too slow for me.
So right now the only thing I'll back me
and show me were the white hoes at. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You want some white girls?
- It ain't what I want to get,
I can get anything I want.
I'm going to get some white
girls you know what I'm saying.
Yeah. Because I'm had to give them what
they want her to give me.
- [Interviewer] And you
have sex with your girls.
- Pardon
- [Interviewer] Do you
have sex with your girls?
- I have before, but I'm
going to tell you this.
It is like no sex for
pleasure or none of that.
I will never be like no
seeing what I'm dealing with
because you know, there'll
be no, no pleasure.
I only, you know, there's a
wham, bam, thank you. Ma'am
- [Interviewer] Are drugs a
part of your life are there
or the girls that work for you?
- I mean, well, you know,
to be honest, you know
I don't want to just speak
on them, you know, personally
but you know, drugs is in the world.
So, you know, it's how it
goes. You just gotta, you know
you gotta be sculpted
and deal with everything
- [Interviewer] Hard for
a girl to do this kind
of work without being drunk
or high or something. Right.
- Well, nah, because I'm tell you this.
It's like the drugs, you
know what I'm saying?
What I'm saying, drugs
more, a lot of migraine.
So that being said the
girls don't necessarily
need the drugs, the drugs are a want.
You understand what I'm saying?
Because they want some drugs
don't mean they are going to .
get it. But you know , mostly
like I treat my hoes good
but I'm going to say, you know,
I, if they want some drugs
and I feel as if they deserve some then
I make it, you know, make a
call to see what I can make
happen but I don't, you
know, I just know on it.
You know, I don't deal with nothing.
You know what I'm saying?
- So now the game has changed
a lot since you were young
right? The laws, the penalties
are stricter now, right?
- Probably
- [Interviewer] the penalties are more
extreme for you guys now.
- Yeah. It's way really
their social media.
She, you know, really came.
So, you know, really, you know
permanent is not really pimp design, but a
pimped saying a holder saying
they're going to pay the same.
So they're busy, just, you
know, mother needs to know how
to move and that is how they need to move.
- [Interviewer] So are
you nice to your girls?
Do you treat them well?
I mean, how do you, how do you
greet them when you see them?
- Yeah. Top of the morning bitch.
What the day buying slow feet don't eat.
Slip on some heels and make me some bills.
- [Interviewer] Have you
done any prison time?
What was that for?
- Mm selling drugs.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of goals do you look for?
This kind of work is not
for every girl right?
- Well, It goes like this.
I don't look for no time.
You understand what I'm saying?
And all I can tell you
a mother needs a little for
me, you know, I'm for hire.
- [Interviewer] So and so the girl gives
you how much of the money?
- that they're going to
give me all the money.
You want to ask a question? You
gave me how much I give her.
- [Interviewer] How much do you give them?
- That again, with their needs,
who needs to get some, eat
nice clothes, you know, outfit her.
I'll let you know, I'll
take all the settles
but I want all the money.
- And what do they get in return for
giving you all the money?
- Can you say that one more time?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Wait, what do you provide?
- Yeah. Security guys.
You know what I'm saying?
And most of all me, you
know what I'm saying?
So, you know, he calls, he calls, Devon
be around me, you know, this
year in free, I ain't free.
- [Interviewer] Does a girl
need to be attracted to you?
Or like you I've heard
that from a lot of guys.
- I only know like when your account
you know what I'm saying?
You know, you don't go looking around
for who you like and using CQ.
I want to don't go like that.
When you're a pimp, you like who? Like you
- [Interviewer] What do
you think the, the core
of the tempered prostitute
relationship is, is
a girl trying to recreate
the childhood relationship
you had with her dad.
- You know, I don't know what
I don't know what they
really be looking for
but whatever they looking
for is all this out of here.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You've
done this a long time.
What's what's the craziest
thing you've seen out there
on the street. The tricks must be nuts.
The tricks must have
crazy behavior, right?
- Yeah. No, whatever, you
know, chicks in the sense
just so you know, don't be
surprised with the trigger do.
Do you know? So I seen a whole lot of.
I would never be surprised
what a trigger would do.
Do you understand me? Okay.
- [Interviewer] And the
girls that worked for you
are they sometimes hustling
stealing stuff like that?
Getting the tricks. Watch.
- Yeah. It's the they, if
you don't do what I say
you don't like me like
somebody else, yeah.
So, you know, I get them off
of the order and you ain't
got no follow it or your not
- [Interviewer] What's more
important to you, love or money?
- Money, Shit, you know, with
money I can buy some love
if you have a family. You understand me?
- [Interviewer] What's the most important
lesson you've learned in
your years of doing this?
- Never trust a hoe,
well, the hoe won't do.
A hoe will do anything.
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- Yeah. 14 kids 10 boys and 4 girls.
- [Interviewer] Are you raising them?
Of course. I'm now alive.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any boys
following in dad's footsteps?
- Yes I do. And it's not all pimp stuff.
You know, I worry I do
everything I need to
do because I'm raising my kids.
Teach them how to be,
you know what I mean?
So they see me get up
and go to work every day.
They know how to bills and get paid.
They don't know how but, you
understand what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Do you have
any regrets in your life?
- Yeah I got some regrets
never trust a hoe.
- [Interviewer] AP Thank you
so much for sharing your story.
Best of luck out there.
When you walk in the door,
what do you say your girls?
- I say bitch. Hold your
breath in by yourself?
(Paper Crunching)